donald trump yesterday took a fiasco
field trip to texas to brag
i guess about coronavirus and also
to brag about how he's supporting coal
and oil and fracking
all things we should actually be making
obsolete rather than
trying to do more of it was really the
stuff of nightmares i'm going to run
through it i watched it live so that you
didn't have to although about 20 000
people did watch it live with me on
youtube twitch and facebook but here are
some of the low lights and again this is
just a reminder
that we cannot have this in the white
house this has to be cleansed
i don't know if we can use bleach or
isopropyl to cleanse it
but we we somehow do need to remove this
now if you're watching along with me
you're going to notice in these videos
that donald trump is particularly sweaty
and extra orange it is texas after all
and i understand it was very very hot
there
it's become super clear to me that
psychologically these events where trump
you know will tour a factory or a
business and then he'll rant to a
hand-picked group of sycophants
these have become sort of placeholders
for the big rallies that trump would
like to be doing to boost his ego
but he can't realistically do right now
because of the virus now donald trump
did have one
of what i would call these major
glitches where he interrupts a word
right in the middle of the word and sort
of has to reset his brain it happened in
the middle of a word i actually can't
identify maybe you can let's take a look
we are now
at the strongest point militarily
we've ever been due to i'll tell you
ted where is ted he was a big leader in
the stand up again ted
these glitches have become very frequent
recently but only one such glitch during
yesterday's event
donald trump later complained that joe
biden's climate plan
is too aggressive which is like well
that's great let's let's be aggressive i
want to see that
and during this part of the rant donald
trump referred to the year
2030 which is a milestone year for joe
biden's climate plan
he referred to it as the year 230 which
is of course a long time ago
seeking an even higher level of
restrictions
mandating net zero carbon emissions
which frankly is impossible
for all new homes offices and buildings
by 230
not possible to do and if you ever did
it
it would cost so much that your home
would be valueless
as i listen to trump rattle off what
biden wants to do
i'm reassured by it i think that's great
let's try to do it
maybe we can't but i want to be you know
trump is doing the opposite trump's
rolling back
restrictions on polluting he's rolling
back vehicle emissions
uh vehicle efficiency and emissions
standards emissions see i kind of like
that portmento
uh i want a guy who maybe is going to
try to do too much and maybe we don't we
don't get there but let's try to do it
trump criticizing that donald trump also
praised texans during this
event as loving america so much that
they couldn't breathe
which is kind of weird imagery given
everything that's going on with the
i can't breathe protests and what
happened with george floyd being choked
to death let's take a look at this
bizarre moment
generations of texas oil workers before
you
gave every last bit of sweat and heart
and grit
that they had to build up this country
they loved our country they loved our
country so much
they couldn't breathe donald trump also
kept accusing
joe biden uh in recent weeks of dementia
here again donald trump couldn't even
say
minneapolis very quickly just like we
did in
minneapolis and just like we will do
another place
so minneapolis ulysses
s grant talking about plasma
instead of plasma trump's having no
shortage of problems himself
and then maybe the most sort of notable
policy related claim that trump made
yesterday
is again this just ridiculous talking
point that
joe biden wants to end the suburbs but
donald trump is going to save them and
this is actually just the dog whistle
stuff we've become accustomed to i'll
explain it after we look at the clip
that's not going to happen and by the
way i just ended the rule on
suburbs you know the suburbs will fight
all of their lives
to get into the suburbs and have a
beautiful home there will be no more
low-income housing forced in to the
suburbs i abandoned and took away
and just rescinded the rule it's been
going on for years i've seen
conflict for years it's been hell
for suburbia we rescinded the rule
three days ago so enjoy your life ladies
and gentlemen
enjoy your life so this is really bad
it's
first of all this is a racially tinged
dog whistle no low-income people
invading the suburbs
is reminiscent of the black folks moving
in next door stuff of the 1950s and 60s
and prior eras
it's just complete racially tinged
red meat for his followers secondly
trump doesn't even really seem to
understand what he did he says he
rescinded a rule now what he's talking
he doesn't even know what he's talking
about but i'll tell you what he's
talking about
there's a 2015 rule the affirmatively
furthering fair housing rule okay
f a f f and it requires
local governments if they're getting
federal funding
they have to study racial bias and
housing patterns and have a plan to
address it that's all like it's so
milk toast it's so almost nothing you if
you get money
you have to study racial bias and
housing and if you determine there is
racial bias you have to address it
that's all it does and trump is now
claiming to be some kind of hero
for rescinding it it's just racist red
meat that's all it is and trump tweeted
something similar
earlier in the day about it widely
derided as despicable saying quote
i am happy to inform all of the people
living their suburban lifestyle dream
capitalized by the way that you will no
longer be bothered
or financially hurt by having low income
housing built in your neighborhood
your housing prices will go up based on
the market and crime will go down
i have rescinded the obama biden affh
rule enjoy this is complete
and total red meat he has now gone on to
say
we should look at delaying the
presidential election
this is an ignorant delusional
narcissistic authoritarian nightmare
there's very little more to say it just
has to end in november
we've all got to vote that that we know
the solution we don't have
you know it's not like one of these
complex problems where we say
you know we've identified a problem but
figuring out a solution is really tough
we're gonna
what could we possibly do voting starts
in four and a half weeks
in some states we're three months almost
to the day a few
three months plus a few days from the we
we know what to do we have the solution
there is no greater power than having a
problem
and knowing the solution let's now
actually carry it out
make sure you're following the david
pakman show at on instagram
david pakman show and follow me on
instagram at david.pacman
check out recent pictures of completely
safe socially distant beach going that i
did
shocking to many people yes i do have
legs although they are not ever visible
during the show
um follow me on instagram at
david.pacman for a break from the bad
news as i like to say
one of our sponsors today is cuts
clothing
offering the most high quality men's
t-shirts you'll be able to find
anywhere and they are giving you 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c u t s solid color
t-shirts are a critical part of
any wardrobe so it could not be more
important
to have t-shirts that you actually love
wearing
and cuts clothing has totally changed
everything i believed i knew about
t-shirts
they've put a ton of thought and
research into the comfort and the
durability of the shirts that they make
all of my cuts t-shirts fit me perfectly
they're not itchy they don't shrink or
fade or
stretch out over time which was the case
with a lot of my pre-cuts t-shirts they
are seriously the most comfortable
t-shirts i've owned
if you're watching on youtube right now
i am wearing the
crew neck split hem black shirt
excellent soft fits perfectly check out
everything they have
they've got polo shirts it's unlike any
polo shirt you've ever worn
as soon as you first put on a shirt from
cuts clothing
you'll be able to tell the difference
between this and other shirts you've
owned in the past
it's really the only t-shirt worth
buying and you'll get fifteen percent
off
when you go to davidpakman.com slash
cuts that's davidpakman.com
c-u-t-s